[Music]
crew is with us in orlando hi prue how
are you
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so my husband and i um have been
trying to
work on their will
but we have a discord agreement on who
would be getting our assets
if both of us passed away we don't have
any children
if i follow the legacy journey principle
which i deeply believe in
it will break my
husband's heart
but if we don't then i have to work
through my resentment towards his family
so could you give me advice as if you
were my father
okay i'm a little bit confused what you
mean by the legacy journey principle
you have no children and you're saying
that i said or the legacy attorney said
to do what with the money
um i believe that
the the assets or the money should be
given to the people who deserve it um
so it's regardless of whether you are
those people are related to you or not
um so let's say if you were to have kids
and they
don't deserve it you don't give it to
them or if you have a family member who
are
entitled yeah i probably would use a
different word if i can i don't use the
word deserve
um i use the word that i'm the manager
of the money for god
and i'm not gonna leave it to someone
who's gonna misbehave with the money
because it's part of my job as the
manager to make sure that another good
manager gets the money that's different
than deserve i'm not sure any of us
deserve that's why i'm better than i
deserve so i'm not sure we deserve
anything but
um but the um
but but you know who's going to do a
good job with it so he wants to leave it
to his family
and i take it you feel like they
misbehave with money
um
i wouldn't
think misbehave but i
felt like
i i do see um why we have a disagreement
now because i don't think they misbehave
with money i think they um they they
don't want to spend so um they don't um
they're not generous
but they're not you know
grateful of course that his sister is
not grateful or generous but i think um
she is a money saver
okay well so she's she's partially good
with money she's good at saving but not
good at giving
okay so um
and uh and obviously you guys you know
you you don't really uh
enjoy her company you don't like her
much
yes um
she say things like whenever you are
with a woman meaning me you forget about
family
but they had a fight you know and then
she never called him or texted me when
my dad passed away
and then but then she blamed him for
for that and
and she criticized that i don't text her
daughter but i mean
i don't think i'm responsible for
texting her daughter i i see you know
her daughter's birthday gifts you know
every year or
sometime we skip it but
okay so do you do you have family that
could be in the equation
i do have family
would you leave them any money
i would but
that's because they um we have different
values though we
they
they have helped us through sickened
things
so my husband and i don't agree that um
you know we would like some of the money
going for them
you do both you do both agree that some
of the money goes to them
right and the only disagreement is he
wants to give some to his sister and you
and his sister don't get along
well actually um she he doesn't think
that she does it but and she said that
um
that money should go to her um kid
because her kid is
innocent which i would agree a hundred
percent if his niece was totally
grateful and generous you know giving
but
how much money are we talking about
well i feel like this is something uh
right now it's not that much it's maybe
like 200 000
because we're still working toward you
know paying off the mortgage
um but that wouldn't be something
that would go on in the long run then
our asset would accumulate
okay well i i tell you what i could do
um i mean sharon and i have a rule on
this kind of stuff whether it's on
giving or spending
or
disagreements of this sort
when when we cannot come to resolution
we choose to do nothing
and so um in terms of leaving money to
his sister or his sister's kid
um right now we're in disagreement
because you don't agree with the way
they live and the way that the
relationship towards you has been and he
feels some kind of a blood
need
based on blood only not based on
relationship to leave her money um right
and so um
what you probably need to ask yourself
is under what circumstances
would you feel good about leaving your
niece or nephew the money because it's
not really the sister and it might be
that we leave it into trust
for that person and when they meet those
circumstances it is released to them
for instance i'll just make up something
that i've seen people do okay
this child needs to agree to
give x number of dollars
are x percentage of the trust away when
the trust is released to prove their
generosity uh this child needs to be
25 years old or whatever number you make
up okay
some people would say something like
they need to go through financial peace
university
they need to learn how to handle money
and handle money the way we teach and uh
so that we're in agreement with that
um and so on
so uh
it is not a reward for being nice to me
though
that that part i don't agree with you on
uh the little nicky knacky stuff i text
somebody somebody didn't text me or
didn't call when my father died or
whatever that's not what this is about
this is about you were given this amount
of money to manage and you're going to
leave it to someone else who also
manages it
the way you would want it managed for
good
and in my case as a christian they're
going to manage it god's ways
and so i'm not leaving money to someone
that's not walking with god in my case
and so that's consistent with our estate
plan and with our kids our kids can
disqualify themselves
uh from our will by
not choosing to manage money or live
their lives that way and they get to
choose that they're adults i can't tell
them what to do but then the result is i
can't leave money to you if you're a
heroin addict because you'll buy more
heroin that would be dumb that would not
be an act of love
and because here's what happens when you
leave people money when anybody gets
money period here's what happens it
magnifies who you already
you're
are
jerk and you get money you become a
colossal jerk
you're kind and compassionate and
generous when you get money you become
unbelievably outrageously generous
you become more of what you are
magnifies
[Music]